i scikit-learn an extra boost our
machine learning frameworks and you can
as part of a Python ecosystem and I'm a
huge fan of these frameworks I use them
for my work and I genuinely find them to
be a joy to use if you're experienced
with scikit-learn an extra boost this
talk is meant to give you some practical
tips for how you can use the cloud to
get your job done better but if you're
new to the frameworks the next couple of
slides will give you a quick
introduction so the first thing to
understand is that so I can't learn an
extra boost or part of a larger Python
ecosystem for data science which is
incredibly rich from low-level libraries
now it like numpy and pandas all the way
up through graphing and matplotlib and
and the frameworks we're talking about
today python has a ton of frameworks to
make data science easy Python was the
most preferred tool cited in Kyle's
recent most recent ml and data science
survey scikit-learn is an open source
framework on Python for doing a wide
variety of ML tasks the name
scikit-learn is derived from being a
toolkit for machine learning that's part
of the scientific Python community and I
have to say I'm personally thrilled to
be here today with David in 2007 David
created scikit-learn as part of a google
Summer of Code project scikit-learn is
by the way often abbreviated SK learn
and I think you'll hear us use both
terms interchangeably so unlike
scikit-learn which supports dozens and
dozens of algorithms actually boost
supports one but does a fantastic job
with it so it's basically actually booth
stands for extreme gradient boosted
decision trees so gradient boosted
decision trees are ensembles of decision
trees in which each subsequent tree
attempts to sort of correct the mistakes
made by the prior trees and it's proven
to be an incredibly effective method of
doing ml I was talking
with Ben Hamner who is the CTO of Kaggle
and he told me that extra boost is
behind almost every recent winning
submission to a cattle competition
except for computer vision competitions
and that brings me to an important point
so neither XG boost nor SK learn is
optimized around deep learning or neural
networks and and that's a key difference
from tensor flow now you're at a Google
conference and you're hearing a lot
about tensor flow so I just want to take
a moment here tensor flow is truly
remarkable
and it you should definitely go and
learn a lot about it but for a class of
problems and I think for a class of
problems that happens to actually be
very common in businesses I think the
ROI from orexi boost and SK learn can be
higher than than then tensor flow you'll
get great results without a ton of
effort so we're gonna focus on three
stages of ML during today's presentation
pre-processing is the stage in which you
make data ready for training training is
the stage in which you take labels data
train on it so that you can predict a
target variable in the future for
unlabeled data and then prediction is
the stage in which you take unlabeled
data and predict new values for it and
how do these frameworks play into these
three phases pre-processing often
requires transformations in numpy or
pandas but scikit-learn also provides
its own libraries for pre-processing you
can do feature selection and feature
engineering with scikit-learn itself and
one of the best things about
scikit-learn is the consistency of its
interface so you can take any algorithm
in scikit-learn and call dot fit on it
and get a trained model and once you
have a trained model you can take any of
them and call dot predict on it and get
predictions out this interface is
incredibly powerful and I think it's
what makes scikit-learn a ton of fun to
use XG Boost supports that same
interface which is really cool so if
you're if you built your a sort of
pipeline to use cycle
you can often switch --xg boost in into
it pretty seamlessly and one of the
things you'll see today is that we're
gonna do some demos the demos all use
scikit-learn and scikit-learn pipelines
but you can easily switch actually boost
into them without much effort so let me
talk about our agenda for the rest of
the talk we're going to divide it into
three sections based on the google cloud
services that are demonstrated and
during these three demonstrations we're
going to refer back to those stages of
ml that I just showed you so in the
first case what we're going to show you
is how you can use Google's building
blocks api's to pre-process unstructured
data so that you can use it in extra
boost and scikit-learn and in the second
phase we're going to talk about compute
engine and how it can help you do ad hoc
data analysis at scale very easily and
without the pain and the difficulty of
distribution I like to refer to that
part of the talk is the part where we
make distributed computing uncool again
and then we're gonna finish by tackling
the topic of production ization in which
we think about how to integrate ml into
your production service in a highly
reliable way I mean that's the part
where we're gonna talk about Google
Cloud ml engine all right so let's dive
in so Google's machine learning building
blocks these are pre-trained models that
you can call in to and they're
accessible by API you basically can use
these models to process us unstructured
data and utilize Google's deep learning
expertise without having to train your
own model building blocks exist for
natural language speech translation
video vision and more coming at this
conference and increasingly you can
customize these API endpoints to your
business's needs with Auto ml so they're
becoming significantly more powerful and
flexible I've talked a little bit about
structured and unstructured data and I
just want to quickly define those
concepts structured data essentially big
tables of rows and columns of strings
and numbers is in the grand scheme
things relatively straightforward to
pre-process you can do it with
expressions it's not that dissimilar
from from spreadsheet operations and if
you need to do it at scale beyond what
fits in memory you can use things like
bigquery or spark or beam or data flow
to do that but unstructured data like
images long paragraphs of text or video
is more tricky to pre-process more
tricky to handle an ml and it's really
weird deep learning and we're a neural
networks shine and there's a lot of
talks here about about those those
topics but an alternate path if you
don't want to write your own neural
network is to utilize Google's Google's
building blocks api's so just as an
example if you have a bunch of images in
your business you could train an
algorithm on them by extracting the
objects within the images and then use
that as structured data in a traditional
ml approach like SK learn or actually
boost or here's another interesting use
case it came to us from a customer
engineer in Japan whose name is hi Otto
yoshikawa I'm also going to take this
moment to just say that in this talk I
will occasionally have to mention
Japanese and and French names and I'm
terrible at pronunciation and I deeply
apologize for butchering these languages
theöto showed that it's possible to use
Google's natural language API to solve a
tricky problem with Japanese text so so
most NLP most natural language
processing starts with extracting the
words that are in a sentence or a
paragraph of text and in English this is
easy you just split the text on the
spaces but in East Asian languages it
can be more difficult because there
aren't spaces between the words so what
hi Otto showed is that you can pass the
sentences to Google's NL API and extract
the tokens out the results he saw were
much better than you get from Python
libraries and with the tokenized text in
hand you can pass it to Google to psych
it learns text preprocessor and go on
your way so let's see this in action I'm
going to switch over to my demo box take
me a second
awesome okay so the demos today are in
Jupiter notebooks and if you're not
familiar with Jupiter notebooks I really
suggest you take a look at them they're
a ton of fun to use they're sort of like
an advanced version of a repple a read
eval print loop where you can execute
code mix and match it it sits and sort
of intermixed documentation with code so
in this demo what we're going to do is
we're going to pre-process headlines
from hacker news
it's a open data set on bigquery and
we're gonna we're gonna try to figure
out whether the headline is from
TechCrunch or from the New York Times by
identifying the most salient words in
the headline let me talk quickly about
the dependencies here basic stuff like
pandas and numpy and then excuse me I'm
out in my second demo all right
basic stuff like pandas and not none pi
as well as text pre-processors from
scikit-learn and to Google client
libraries so the first here reads data
from bigquery and then the second here
communicates with the natural language
API so let's run this line of code here
and you know what I'm gonna restart my
kernels so that I just clear all the
output I don't want to spoil the
surprise all right let's start this
again
perfect so we've imported our
dependencies and now we're going to
query the data from bigquery this is
something I really love about notebooks
you can mix and match actually different
forms of code so in this notebook for
instance we're match mixing Python code
with these bigquery magics magics are
add-ons you can install and OPIC
environments to do particular things in
this case the bigquery magic allows us
to write a query here and with just very
very simply simple amount of code read
it into a panda's data frame so here's
that data frame or a preview of it the
source here is the target variable and
the sentence the headline
is here on the right so let's do a first
attempt to tokenize the scikit-learn and
we'll see the the problem so the problem
here that you see is that the English
text is successfully split into its
constituent words but the Japanese text
is left completely alone which is
because scikit-learn is just naively
splitting on the spaces so now let's use
Google's natural language API we create
a language service client from the
Google client library and for each piece
of Japanese text we pass it to this
tokenized function what the tokenized
function does is it calls the analyzed
syntax method on that client takes the
return value from that and extracts the
tokens the tokens are joined together
with spaces and inserted back into a new
column in the data frame called
tokenized text and now if we run this
last cell in the notebook we'll just
show that we've solved the problem we've
run the exact same set of code but this
time the Japanese text is successfully
split into words it's a very sort of
like simple example but I think what's
cool about it is it hides a ton of
complexity so let's go here we go oh by
the way the links to all the code are
going to be available in the last side
of the deck so Google's high-level
machine learning api's can be useful in
pre-processing data but how about
infrastructure-as-a-service
are we really going to talk about
virtual machines in this talk about
machine learning and the the answer is
resounding yes so what kind of scaling
challenges to users of scikit-learn and
extra boost typically run into well
skilling can require more memory if your
data set is very large it can require
more CPU or GPU or TPU if the best ml
algorithm for the task is
computationally intense and it can
require more processes or threads if you
have a big hyper parameter space to
explore and so when you need to scale
you typically think about parallelizing
your work so let me talk about different
you can parallelize your work hyper
parameter tuning is embarrassingly power
parallel
embarrassingly parallel because it's so
easy to parallelize the only information
that needs to be shared from the workers
back up to the scheduler is just the
final results and then the scheduler
just picks the best one both SK learn
and XP boost allow HP tuning to be
parallelized also there are ensemble
methods of ml like random forests that
can be parallelized and pre processing
can be parallelized so you can switch
from pandas to desk tasks implements the
pandas dataframe api but does so in a
parallelizable cut way i mean it's super
cool and I think when many people think
about parallelization they immediately
think about distribution across multiple
nodes and I think that's because our
industry has made a ton of amazing
progress in the last few years through
distributed computing however often
times you can actually get a lot done
with a single node and it can be really
easy to do using large compute instances
to do your work is becoming increasingly
more and more of a reality as costs come
down and the capacity of nodes increases
dramatically so here to tell you more
about this as David David corn Oppo it
leads the ML team at cogent labs which
is a business in Japan that specializes
in applying deep learning to b2b markets
and as I mentioned in 2007 he created
scikit-learn thanks good thank you can
you hear me
[Applause]
good for the sound you can already hear
me okay so thank you Steve thank you for
having me I'm excited to be here first
time at Google next so positive I
mentioned I've been working for almost
one year now at cogent labs it's a
startup in Japan Tokyo where we do deep
learning and so we try to apply deep
learning to problems that were difficult
to solve before so focused on we have a
protocol Takaki which is Japanese on
writing recognition using deep learning
we have a protocol kodoku for doctrine
understanding and we have also like a
system to the time series production but
today actually I'm not here to talk
about deep running but I'm here to talk
about a lot of the work that happened
before like when you need to deal with
the data because Steve already mentioned
when you do a machine learning you need
to actually spend quite a bit of time on
the pre-processing so it's kind of
unsexy part of the data science and
machine learning very strictly speaking
when you work on product that's most of
what you spend your time on more than on
the models themselves and this part is
actually not that different whether
using machine learning like traditional
machine learning like scikit-learn or
whether using deep running through
frameworks like tons of room so it yeah
I want to talk a bit more about that
part actually
so like the example I will use to
illustrate with my points is is using
one of the project I've been working on
at cogent labs for the financial time
series forecasting so we did this
project in coordination with one of the
biggest brokerage company in Japan and
you use basically deep running to do
time series prediction for real-time
volume
prediction of the Tokyo Stock Exchange
and the product has been live since last
month's actuary here like to use the
deep learning algorithm you need data
and you know it's kind of treasom today
like you know the more data you have the
better it is and so you have this famous
paper from like 10 years ago by Aaron
heavily and Peter Novick
about like unreasonable effectiveness of
data so Peter Novick is the head of
research at Google actually another
thing you mentioned early on when he was
at Google is at Google we don't have
better algorithm but you have better
we have more data and I could say like
some things that really I knew that
already intuitively before but like
something that really kind of you know
stayed with him like when he was at
Google was how like even simple
algorithm can work so well when you have
a lot of data so if this whole argument
about in reason of malefic knees never
theta and how you can generally improve
your product not by changing the model
but just by using a more data
so with this Wolfgang about you know
it's almost a fad at that point about
large data big data and you're the mole
data you have and the better it is right
you have more matera internet blah blah
blah so what can you do like do you need
to do like this repeat computing you
need to always just hydraloop only have
like two engineers or I can do this
right
so based is you know at that point is
almost a fad but still real thing for
some companies where you have large data
to use for you algorithm and supreme is
when you have a lot of stuff engineers
is I kind of like using tools for this
with computing because it's fun and you
have a lot to do right you have all
these great technologies like Hadoop
Spock Kafka beam some of them will be
mentioned or have been mentioned already
in this conference and so yeah as I said
like engineers I love working with this
with their system because it's fun but
you know like is really large data
really eating the world so to speak so
this paper I really like it's a bit old
now but I think the lessons are still
relevant today like nobody ever got
fired for using Hadoop and so I'm like
again the numbers are a bit old because
as from 2012 but I've noticed the same
thing you know in my previous job and
even currently like in this paper in
2012 they look at what was the median
size of job in Hadoop and Microsoft and
Yahoo the median size was below 14
gigabyte
at Facebook 90% of the hard jobs they
were using at a time where for job input
size of below 100 gigabyte so with joke
we're like a lot of people like to say
oh I have a lot of data I have gigabyte
of data so I'll use Hadoop right and so
there's this famous blogger and a
conference speaker a Gary Burnett
I had this joke like I have this new
consulting services where you know you
bringing your big data problem and I
will tell you what you did actually
is small enough to fit in Ram you pay me
$10,000 and then you don't have to spend
half a million dollars on infrastructure
and if it sounds like you know almost
trivial right like you're like I will
never make that mistake right of course
you have like a small data set I will
not use Hadoop but there's something I
keep saying like at the beginning of
this year PI data in London I was
talking to this guy working for a hedge
fund and he said like when you join like
verities team of 15 people doing scalar
distributed system for data set there
was 40 gigabyte if I had all of them and
build a system that was a bit better
design so that's one big lesson I want
you to remember you know maybe some
people don't make that mistake I mean
when you have a bit less expenses you
have to do this mistake but don't over
architect and the thing is when you do
like machine learning like the typical
data size for other canal Aziz is often
not that big sure you have more and more
data and of course if your Google you
have a large data set if you like other
companies have a very larger side but
most companies they don't have that that
are that big of a data and the thing
that is interesting as well like maybe
you're storing more and more data but
the data you need to look at when you
look for a new problem to solve or maybe
to improve an existing algorithm you
don't need to use all the data at once
right like especially at the beginning
when you do a dark analysis you know
exactly what you're looking for you want
to understand a bit better your data you
can use a subset of this data to do the
analysis so the size of the data for
analysis you know the same size as the
data you need for storing it's very easy
to underestimate the work the
engineering work you need to deal with
like effective data architecture like
you know for people of use Hadoop they
know like you know you don't set up a
dupe in one hour and then you're done
and you're using it right you need
people to take care of it like like
masternodes fair you know like some of
the hardware failure and you need to
take that's a lot of 42 to deal with it
and especially when you're small company
I think it's easy to underestimate the
loss of what I call data agility that is
the ability to be able to to not scale
the amount of data to scale the number
of experiments you can do with the data
like having data this model you can
easily visualize it you can understand
it it's it's really important for some
class of problems as well and again you
know like most of the work and machine
learning when you work on product is not
on the model itself but everything
around so if you optimize the part where
you need to have like a doc analysis
when you need to do an analysis if you
optimize that part to be like simple
where like all your data scientists can
walk on like a setup where they don't
have to fight the system to get the data
you can get actually lot back because
you can be faster and you can develop
new model faster understand your data
faster or plot the data faster okay so
what was the link of this observation
with like a Google cloud so again there
are getting bigger
you know I've mentioned before don't try
to overtake too much your data
architecture but something that is
interesting when you think about like
cloud cloud services and gzip in
particular is you can get a really
really large VM now like recently GCP
announced that you can have VM with 4
terabyte of memory that's a lot of data
you can keep in memory on one machine
and when you look at the trend of like
what is the data typical data size that
people use in data science actually you
see it's kind of plateauing like so it's
just one there are some one but you have
this sort KD nugget is a famous data
science website and every day every year
sorry is they do a survey to ask people
you know what is the typical data size
you're handing etc and actually you see
that for last few years like the median
data size of the data that people look
at is flattering at a few hundred gig
it and five years ago a few hundred
gigabyte here maybe you had to use
Hadoop at least you know you need to
think of it you couldn't need trigger II
but today a few hundred of gigabytes if
I have to deal with this today I know
what I will do if I can put it there on
the cloud I will just put them on a
large data another VM way I can load
everything in rum and then anything
become much easier for me and I don't
have to overthink too much I was an
engineering part it's not just about the
RAM okay with the CPU it's kind of abuse
but also like you know at least on GCP
you have also like fast look at are you
available right you can create VMs that
have nvme SSD we have more than one
gigabyte per second
like like throughput when reading from
disk so all of this together means you
can have like very powerful machine
where you can actually get a lot done
without going too early to distribution
it's the advantage of very obvious right
if you are scientist who are maybe not
so strong in the software engineering
side they can focus on send domain
expertise so I don't need to spend time
learning about Hadoop about Pig hive
whatever and they keep all the tools all
the interactivity of the tools that
people like to use in their science
especially in Python and some of the
tools that Steve mentioned before so you
keep interactivity on single machine and
you keep like using the notebook is easy
using macro click SIBO on pandas all of
that keeps tabs easy so concretely if
you look at I was mentioning before this
project we do it we did with a
investment bank in Japan so we have a
fairly typical problem like we use
deepening after but doesn't matter so
much from what I'm talking about here so
we use a market data so we have tick
data so tick data for people not
familiar with just you know like the
price of each stocks at each moment is
coming from the market so concretely we
have like between one and two hundred
gigabyte of CSV files
sorry least semi aggregated we have like
50 million points per month so we had a
bit more than two years so we have a few
like more than 1 billion data points and
some of the like analysis we had to do
was pretty like easy to paralyze if you
want like some pre-processing you know
it's each row independently so you could
paralyze that very easily some things
are a bit like
easy to paralyze I quit some playing you
had this thing called open beam
detection it's boring but basically it's
kind of reclusive so it's more difficult
to paralyzed and at the beginnings of
people setting we had was quite versus
angry like you needed more than 100 year
by the run just to deal with one of the
CSV file we had to make it a bit more
concrete just show a bit like how it
looks like so you don't need to
understand the numbers but no like when
you use a market data like the prime is
you know each market data provider has
like different like conventions so you
need to convert between like you need to
convert between different market data
provider to a common format so like kind
of boring but again fairly typical
things like removing some characters in
the symbol all of these kind of things
and we need to do that like for like
quite a few data points for several
billions and so we need to speed this up
and so you may wonder why do you need to
speed this up right like people say
singing you only need to do the ones you
can say that into like data frames or
maybe you can say that you do pack a
file which is a more modern salutation
format that can be said as quickly from
and to disk from on the data frame but
the prime is at the beginning well not
exactly which kind of processing we had
to do because again like this market
data pretty complicated and different
banks actually deal with them
differently and have different
conventions so you had to go back and
forth with just a customer quite a few
times and so like the speed of
processing was actually kind of
important because if it takes one day
versus like one week or I cannot make a
difference when you need to talk to the
customer back and forth and so just by
using larger VM on on Google Cloud and
like you know nothing fancy you know
pandas your by scripting a bit of a pile
option to exacts you actually could get
quite a lot done and having the big VM
are all straight right quickly
expression especially in expiratory
phases and I think Bing VMs really and
others are so to convert the CSV very
quickly to some other file format that
are more efficient on the disk and
memory so easy takeaway here is you know
there was this fashion of you know
always scale isn't a little scaling up
does it scale well actually for a lot of
things getting up actually
does care right especially with a cloud
now it's quite easy to get like really
large VM and as long as you do that you
know like for other canal Izzy's
actually thing it works pretty well you
can keep it eration quickly when I dove
for doing an attic analysis I think VM
actually getting bigger more quickly
than data are getting bigger at the same
time you have like two that become more
memory efficient so if I solve for
pandas like the rule of thumb for like a
West makini is a credit of pandas is if
you need to deal with a data set of size
X journey is the rule of thumb is you
need five x - 10 x of ram to deal with
this like comfortably into pandas but
now it's tools like arrow like this
factor becomes smaller so it's actually
more memory efficient so for given
amount of RAM you actually can get more
done on get larger data and some of
those lessons like they're not specific
to other can edit like just
pre-processing or other canal Aziz but
actually you can apply this in later
phases as well of your project so one of
the way I like using these kind of
technologies is for testing and
continuous integration like doing
continuous integration for machine
learning models is pretty difficult
right like how do you add unit tests for
machine learning models how do you right
now it's not it's not as mature as for
like standard software engineering and
sometimes one of the issue is that it's
text a lot of time to just test even
simple things in your models especially
when you do deep learning
well here again if you can launch on
demand just for like half an hour like
very large VR is a lot of course you can
actually get away with like simple
solution and you don't need to again
over architect like too early so it's
not all the lessons I'm not giving here
those are simple tricks and maybe it's
trivial for most of you but you can use
them not just for other colleges but
also like for like testing integration
okay I will give back to Steve perfect
thanks so much thanks David
[Applause]
perfect so as you think about scaling up
your training on single nodes on compute
engine I want to call your attention to
two resources that I think can be really
helpful from Google so the first is
called compute engine burst training and
there's a link there it'll also be at
the end of the deck it's all on github
it's just a pattern for doing your work
and basically it's a set of scripts that
allow you to automatically provision a
machine kick off training export the
results of training to cloud storage and
shut down the machine that's all done
for you so that you can basically get
your code correct on a sample of your
data on your local machine and then when
you want to train on your full data set
you do that on the cloud but you do it
in a way that minimizes your costs I'm
so you're able to Geoff's provision that
very you know for terabyte machine for
just the period that you need and the
other became available just about two
weeks ago on cloud launcher it's called
the deep learning VM image and while it
says deep learning I think it's really
helpful for XE boost and SK learn as
well
it automatically installs pandas and
numpy and other common dependencies it
automatically starts up Jupiter
provisions in SSH tunnel and gives you a
little command to basically browse to
that to Jupiter from your local machine
again none of this is rocket science but
it can just make your life a little bit
easier okay so now it's time for our
last section cloud ml engine this is all
about production ization and taking your
code and moving into a production
service which means that it's highly
available that you have a repeatable
process for deploying and updating and
that it responds to real-time changes in
demand and so if your service relies on
prediction for real customer experiences
or if you regularly retrain your model
on new data as it comes in the bottom L
engine can be a real help and at this
conference we have announced that
scikit-learn and actually boosts are
both supported in for training and
prediction and both services are
generally available
so first let's talk about prediction
it's simple from extra boost or
scikit-learn just export the model to a
file upload it to cloud ml engine you'll
have a rest endpoint that you can use to
handle predictions cloud ml engine runs
on Google infrastructure so Google sres
are holding the pager and as you'll see
in this demo I'm about to show you it
can help you avoid training serving skew
so trading serving skew happens when you
process data differently in training and
in prediction and it can lead your
predictions to just not meet not live up
to the expectations set during training
and the solution to avoid training
serving skew or one aspect of avoiding
it is to make sure that you share your
pre processing code between trading and
prediction and cloud ml engine together
with scikit-learn pipelines can help you
do exactly that so let's take a look at
a demo all right so again this demo is
in a jupiter notebook and this time
we're going to predict the weight of
babies again it's a data set on bigquery
public data predict the weight of babies
given basic information that we might
have available when an expectant mother
walks into a clinic we know the agent of
the mother and the father the gender of
the baby and the length of the pregnancy
in this demo we've got a couple of
interesting dependencies from
scikit-learn that I just want to show
you the first is a dictionary vectorizer
this is what we use to one hotend code
so it's a really slick piece of
scikit-learn that just takes categorical
data and automatically one hot signal
encodes it some of you may call that
dummy encoding not one hot encoding but
it basically turns categoricals into
numbers so that they're easily
understandable by an ml algorithm we're
training using a random forest but it
could be any model we're joining
together those two pieces together in a
cycling on we've got utility functions
for splitting our training and test set
and job Lib for exporting the model
we're going to use the discovery API
from the Google API client to issue
predictions basically just build up a
rest request and we are going to also
use
to read the data so let's run this and
that's great
again we load our data from bigquery and
here's the data the weight here is the
leftmost column that's the target
variable the rest of the columns are the
features we're using to predict it so
let's do some basic data processing
separating out our labels from our
features making sure that our
categorical data are of type string so
that the dictionary vectorizer will
correctly handle them and then splitting
our training and test set and
constructing the pipeline at this point
we have a pipeline ready but we actually
haven't done anything with it yet on
this next step and again this is calling
the dot fit method fits the pipeline to
the data and this shows us this output
shows us that the pipeline is correctly
fit so what that did is it actually ran
both steps in succession first it ran
the dictionary vectorizer then it
trained the model and then on the local
machine we can then call dot predict on
the pipeline and get our predictions now
all of this has been done locally which
is all well and good until you want to
run it as part of a production service
so now let's do that so we're gonna use
job Lib to dump out the data to the
local file system and then copy it up to
cloud storage there's another cool thing
about notebooks here is that we're
mixing together a magic that sets an
environment variable with a call to the
shell which calls gsutil and copies up
the data so the data is up there now and
now let's create a model and you can see
I've practiced this demo nine times all
right we're gonna create the model and
the model is just a container for us to
then put versions of the model and those
are the add that which will actually
serve predictions so the meat of the
work is this command and I'm going to
run it and talk you through it it's a
call to G cloud and we're creating a
version of the model asynchronously that
just means the notebook returns and
continues execution while waiting for
the model to finish we're passing it the
model and version name we just created
we're specifying that the framework is
scikit-learn so the other two framework
options are tensorflow
and extra boost the runtime version of
1.8 is a Claddagh mel engine runtime
version that specifies a version of
scikit-learn
and a version of other dependencies that
are available to us we points to that
file that we just uploaded to cloud
storage and we also specify that at all
points in time there should at least be
one node servicing traffic I may mention
earlier but one of the cool things about
cloud ml engine is it scales up or
skills to zero and if you have zero
nodes servicing traffic you pay nothing
which is really nice but you may your
business may require you to always have
one node servicing data because there is
a small latency cost of tens of seconds
if you're the first request to sort of
provision a model if you want to avoid
that you can do this okay now let us see
if the model is ready it is not ready
yet let's give him one more second and
then I'll call the one before that all
right it's ready so that shows you about
how long it takes for the model to
deploy and this last cell in the
notebook is Python code it could be any
language you want this is just an HTTP
request to a rest endpoint we use the
discovery API to make it easy to build
up the request and then we issue it
passing the test instances to in the
payload we and we print the predictions
out to the notebook and if these numbers
look familiar
six point four four seven two point two
one and it's because those are the same
numbers that we saw up here which is
just an indication that shows that we've
basically taken the same logic that was
running locally and we've moved it up to
the cloud
cool awesome
but prediction is usually only part of a
larger end-to-end pipeline that can
involve retraining as well so here to
tell you a little bit about how that can
work is Laurent candle ei Laurent is a
senior data scientist at OU kado
[Applause]
thank you Steve let me start with a
quick context
okay dough has been an online retailer
in UK since 15 years in and it has known
great success
thousands of order are placed every day
through our website or application then
products are picked up by hundreds of
robots in our huge our automated
warehouses and happy drivers come to
your homes to deliver your goods
whenever you want and with time a guru
has also become more than just a
retailer it has become a tech company
robust enough to sell its technology to
others from the website and the app to
the full system of delivery using the
full automated warehouses and more big
data and AI some of the biggest retailer
in the world join our adventure like
Morrison's in UK bomb Bremen Spain
Casino in France so base in Canada UK
and Sweden and Kroger here in United
States so I have five minutes to go to
the point so let me jump to an example
where the experience of Aikido in big
data and AI can help other retailer
fraud detection is a classical problem
that we face in online retail orders
being delivered and never paid for how
can we face that with machine learning
for example features can be derived from
orders and pasts along with the
non-class of fail payments or not to a
machine learning algorithm that we learn
a model that will then be able to
predict if a new incoming order will
probably be associated with failed
payment or not type of rules that such
an m/l models can learn is if you pass
more than three orders in the future for
more than 500 pounds each and you let us
less than 24 hours to do the delivery
well your orders are suspicious and
remember one important thing we are
speaking about big data here with all
the retailers in the world that turned
our adventure so the big question is how
to embrace the challenge of quickly
building scalable machine learning
solutions
for prediction as quickly as legend to
the problem let me jump to the solution
it's called Google cloud platform a
great environment to run machine
learning on the clouds you can start
with your data
lying in Google bigquery and run some
standard SQL to join your data coming
from different resources and run some
initial computation of features you can
then go to Google Data float runs on
Apache beam to run some more complex
that are processing like data
normalization for example or data
transfer to other resources like data
store that can be used as fast data
access solution to expose some of the
pre computed feature you will need at
serving time you can also use Google
Cloud Storage to store all your data
sets as files that will then be read by
Google Cloud ml engine to learn a model
and expose it as a rest endpoints and
thus be ready to serve prediction in
real time and here is the important
thing when we run the the analysis of
comparing machine learning algorithms to
face this problem we found that XG
boosts like in many cases were algorithm
reaching the best predictive
performances but we chose to go to
tensorflow neural network instead
because it was embedded in Google Cloud
ml engine and thus we were allowed to
train and predict in the cloud and thus
we were offering a solution to quickly
go to prediction and to be scalable we
would also have liked to use for example
decision trees for example in
scikit-learn
to be able to understand the output of
the models and the prediction but again
we chose to go to tons of low neural
network and basically with the work of
Steve's team this conscious decision
not needing anymore we can take the best
of all machine learning algorithm using
extra boost and scikit-learn on the
cloud deploy easily train and predict on
the cloud and so we can now have better
predictive performance with eg boosts
and the explanation for fraud detection
can be important because it can be
interesting if you provide the
information to a human to explain that
you use you think that this order is
fraudulent because of the basket content
or because of the past behavior of the
customer or because of the payment
method that is used but then if you want
to really take decision automatically
for legal reasons you need to be able to
explain your prediction so this explain
ability for forests is important so yeah
basically Big Data machine learning made
easy on the cloud what's next Steve
[Applause]
awesome I'm always happy to take credit
for things but I also want to just note
that I saw Marielle and Robby rock into
the room a few minutes ago and they're
actually they were I did work on it but
they were really the folks who did most
important so thank you so let's sum up
by dispelling a couple of myths I think
you'll sometimes hear that you need
neural networks in order to do machine
learning these days and I don't think
that's true I think hopefully we've
shown you today that scikit-learn an
extra boost can be really helpful in
solving a bunch of business problems
with ml and if you do have unstructured
data like images or audio files and you
want to make sense out of them another
option instead of building your own
neural network or certainly something to
consider is to process them through our
building blocks api's and then take the
structure out of that and then use extra
boost or scikit-learn people may tell
you that you need to leave the Python
ecosystem to scale I also don't think
this is true I think using some of the
the techniques that we showed you today
you can scale up on single machines and
get a ton of amazing work done without
having to sort of go to a distributed
framework and people may tell you that
the only way to production eyes is to
embrace containerization and certainly
containerization has its place and there
is lots of places where it's very very
appropriate but I think for many folks
the ease-of-use of a managed service
like cloud ml engine can be very
compelling
[Music]